Hey Youtubers it's Charlie, this is going
to be my Star Wars Q&A.
Thank you everybody that submitted quesitons
on my trailer video.
Hopefully you were able to stop crying long
enough to go to school this morning or go
to work, but let's get going.
So first question squeaker kid asks why did
the tie fighter shoot green lasers in the
rebel shoot red lasers I'm so confused that
is actually exactly why they the two things
to certain colors on screen so that is really
easy to understand just from a visual perspective
we know who is fighting who were even if it's
not a battle scene into different groups of
characters have different color schemes with
their costumes with resistance characters
they dress a certain way they have a certain
color palette the Imperial characters are
ours is a the first order characters they
have their own color palette to so say you
are deaf or you are taking a deaf person to
the movie and they couldn't hear what the
characters were say they'd be able to look
at the screen and know who is who so the tie
fighter shoot green laser so that it's easy
you know when there's a lot of action on screen
and things are moving really fast you'll be
able to tell who is firing on who and because
they've always been green so it is kind of
a double answer this question Camino asks
do you think that on or someone from the original
trilogy will die in these movies have a bad
feeling on Han Solo what he is definitely
like a high a high likelihood of Han Solo
but this Daisy Ridley picture I'll just put
up right now and a lot of people think that
she is crying over Chewbacca I guess you just
thinking that this might be for down here
not just because she's crying doesn't mean
the characters died but she seems really upset
in this movie so very clearly somebody close
to hers probably going to die the thing is
is we really don't know what her relationship
is relative to the other characters when the
movie picks up presumably this will be about
the new characters coming together Poe Dameron
Finn and Ray and then intersecting with the
original trilogy characters so that the third
act of the film she will probably be firmly
on team resistance the thing about killing
original trilogy characters are is that it
has to feel natural to the plot like a campy
gimmicky it has to be someone that the will
make you crap your pants but won't make you
quick the movie that are trying to intentionally
harm the audience so you have to ask yourself
on the list of characters that is most unforgivable
to kill was like the lowest on that totem
pole never kill Chewbacca in the books of
long time ago they've already kind of wreck
combat out with episode seven like they were
liberty change the expanded universe because
of that so that the fandom had already processed
Chewbacca's death and men made their peace
with it than I think he would probably be
the most okay of characters that it is not
okay to kill mean it's still not okay to kill
characters that you love but if they don't
kill anybody in the resistance starts to feel
invincible so you are killing a beloved character
is one way to let you know that there is a
threat next question Ygnacio asked me the
Kylo Ren might be Luke's kid if not why the
obsession with Darth Vader how is he force
sensitive will I mean this is all about the
force awakening the force is this mysterious
intelligent alive thing so naturally it's
going to pop up in unexpected places I should
actually say this right now what I'm really
hoping is as they don't over explain the force
we don't need to know exactly how the force
works part of its magic is in its ministry
that's why a lot of people got really upset
with the idea of medical or instant like oh
you mean the force is it like this mysterious
then thing is is like a biological thing you
just born with so yes there is like a genetic
hereditary aspect of the force and you said
I definitely think the Kylo Ren's tied to
the original trilogy characters in a familiar
way at all I don't like you to try to get
into too many spoilers but is all really rumors
at this point but no I do not think he is
Luke Skywalker son I don't expect Luke Skywalker
to have any children and the movie I think
you'll be more of an Obi-Wan character although
depending on what material looking at Obi-Wan
also had a child himself to or at least a
relationship with someone just trying to base
a lot of your theory crafting on establish
Canon typically actual stories you in in all
movies and TV tend to be a lot simpler than
what fan theories make them out to be just
make your series as simple as possible based
on the material we've seen in what we know
about the original trilogy characters like
Luke Skywalker probably kinda went off into
the wilderness to study the force by himself
so we probably didn't have a lot of time to
have children if anyone in the series is going
to be having children it's going to be Han
and Leah and I don't the the doing Jason and
Jane out but I do think that some of these
characters I mean I think it's pretty obvious
when you look at the poster here but I think
their children will be a big part of the movie
next question Megan honor asks I've never
seen a Star Wars film but I'm planning on
catching up with the film series until the
new movies come out in what order do I have
to see them are not interested in elsewhere
stories just the basics were a lot yummier
to just talk about the main films will there's
two different ways to watch it you can do
it episode 1 to 6 in that story really becomes
like the fall and redemption of Vader or you
can watch the original trilogy first and then
go back and watch the prequels and that makes
the story little bit more about Luke so really
it just depends on which character you think
is the main protagonist of the series is Star
Wars a story all about Darth Vader or is it
a story about Luke Skywalker redeeming his
father it just changes the narrative a little
bit depending on which order you watch the
movies and so depends on who your favorite
character is like if your favorite characters
Luke and watch the original trilogy first
then watch the prequels but if you're hard-core
Darth Vader fan been just watch it episode
want episode six you also to remember the
clone wars the animated movie that came before
the TV series is also Canon two so you can
add that movie into technically there seven
films next question low-flow asks who will
be the new bounty hunters or hunters there's
that I mean is that the gonna be new bounty
hunters if you member all those scenes with
Darth Vader talking to bounty hunters with
banner droids nonhuman bounty hunters they're
going to be all kinds of those in the new
movie they haven't revealed to any of them
are going to be yet but I'm actually really
excited to see new bounty Hunter droids is
actually a bounty hunter battle droid in the
novels right now if your big Old Republic
fan that you know you're looking for Hunter
killer Joyce to show up all that stuff is
going to be in their yes lots of bounty hunters
employed by the first order is the same way
Darth Vader employed bounty hunters Kylo Ren
has this vision quest to complete Vader's
mission so he needs a track a lot of stuff
down and if he's obsessed with Darth Vader
it makes sense that he would try to track
down those original trilogy characters to
kill the last of the Jedi and get Anakin Skywalker's
light saber next question Lou Rick asks the
light saber question do you think that they're
setting Ray up to have a dual blade a light
saber to be nice to see one again based on
what they said about the movie it sounds like
there are can be Jedi all over the place building
lifesavers as is in funeral fining Anakin
Skywalker's light saber is a huge deal there
there become incredibly rare I do think that
Ray is totally force sensitive and she will
become a Jedi during this new trilogy Kathleen
Kennedy wouldn't harp on the role of women
in Star Wars if she were gonna let one of
them become a Jedi and the movie it be completely
disingenuous but I think her path is going
to be similar to Luke Skywalker's path in
the original trilogy he kinda got the handicap
because they gave him his father's light saber
when he first started out but eventually he
constructed his own lifesavers what I'd like
to see is a rate not start out with a light
saber and construct her own over the course
of the new trilogy and just double bonus if
it happens to be a double bladed light saber
but even if she doesn't fight with a light
saber in the first movie you have to remember
the you can use the force to strengthen normal
mealy objects so she can still use her staff
like a nonlethal version of a light saber
just whacked the shed out of people next question
Jack asks C-3 PO is an in any of the footage
I wonder why will I think there are a couple
reasons one because they mostly want to focus
on the new characters that's why there's so
little of the original cast into because he
actually looks a little bit different he has
some like some red coloring on one of his
arms I think they just try not to give away
what has happened to C-3 PO since the last
trilogy is adroit they can keep repairing
them so obviously he and R2 are still around
and whatever happened to C-3 PO might end
up being spoiled 327 just they're holding
back on that next question Sam asks what you
think that Leah is upset about does this mean
Luke is dead when I mean it doesn't mean the
Luke is that it just me she's really upset
about what's been happening it looks like
the resistance gets its ass handed to it if
you member the way Empire strikes back end
it just with the rebels and all the main characters
getting the she kicked out of them by the
Empire Darth Vader I think that's why she
is sad like you know bunch of people probably
dying she is the way to the resistance on
her shoulders and also throwing some theory
crafting on their possibly some of her children
are main characters and are doing things that
are making her very upset nobody can hurt
you like family members can next question
Alec asks do you think that Finn is going
to get trained by Luke well supposedly Luke
is going to be a bigger thing during episode
eight so I think that they'll be a lot of
Jedi training in that movie like episode seven
is all about discovery getting the light saber
episode eight will be pushing deeper into
that just to go back to Empire strikes back
Luke you have to go to the Diggle bus system
to learn from Yoda to apply be a similar arc
at some point in the new trilogy so they might
put that off to episode eight so regardless
of like other rumors about Luke I do think
that will be a conduit for the new characters
learning more about the force but he will
be the only person the person talking in the
trailer to Daisy Ridley saying the force is
calling to you let it and I think that's Lupita's
character at the new characters will learn
about the force the dark side piecemeal from
all kinds of different sources until eventually
like episode eight or episode nine they go
to the source they go to Luke who can explain
everything in great detail next question Jonathan
asks about it 104 DT that that's the new death
Star showing off its firepower also have a
seat inside Lou and Davis Adam driver Oscar
Isaac and Justin Timberlake sing a song about
outerspace pretty awesome in retrospect yet
that's totally coincidence that you people
don't plan things out like that the weight
you with a cast movies I definitely think
that that is the star killer bases in a moment
similar to when Princess Leia watched all
ran be destroyed somatically a lot of moments
in the new films will harken back to moments
in the original trilogy there just are mixing
and matching a lot of characters we also to
remember the trailers are cut a little misleading
so the scene with Kylo Ren and Poe Dameron
might not come right before this weapon looks
like it's getting tested that this could be
completely unrelated but I mean they have
a super weapon the probably get a destroyed
planet tested out and make one of the characters
watch like look at what this can do there's
no hope for you give up now thank you so much
stuff for 70 questions is going to be so much
fun a price are doing a lot more Star Wars
in November I don't know how many more clips
and trailers were going to get full we probably
will see some new stuff to do some new weird
things trying to market the film so a lot
of the new information we get actually comes
from like toy releases or video games so be
some battlefront stuff happening really soon
to do congratulations to my Star Wars giveaway
winner to help us saying you into IMAX passes
for Star Wars in December so be sure to private
message me on the back and my channel in and
we can work out the details I can find a way
to get this stuff to you what to do I think
you know for my next couple Star Wars giveaways
like whatever I do Star Wars videos is I'll
just do ticket giveaways just because it seems
like it's really hard for people to get tickets
in don't worry there are actually still a
lot of tickets available online so you should
be able to get one no problem worse case scenario
you just you can't see it on Thursday night
you have to wait till Friday to see it what's
going to happen next this is there's a new
episode of the flash tonight am in a post
my video for after that airs on a new round
of the reverse flash ring giveaway so just
look out for that if you guys are watching
the flash it is freaking awesome this year
and I am going to do a Gotham video to images
post a little bit later in the week so as
I post new videos I'll just provide updates
on videos that I've rescheduled is just so
much Star Wars stuff at the beginning the
week I just had to move some stuff around
white as way for all that flash stuff to post
you can click here for my episode to be here
to catch up on that and you can click here
for all my Star Wars footage and you know
the trailer like 1 billion more times just
it's okay to cry totally okay so thank you
so much for watching, let's high five and
I'll see you guys tonight!